Takk for att du så med.
Takk for at du så med.
It needs to be absolutely perfect to get, to not get a deduction of 0.1
So, let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's say 15 steps
So what would that be?
We'll leave that there on this side
And we'll come back and we'll just calculate the score at the end
So, major mistake
Say you're supposed to turn to the left when you turn to the right
That would be a major mistake
So, obviously we do want to try and avoid any of these major mistakes
So, after we've done our pattern, that's when we move on to the presentation side
So, the presentation, as you can see, it's from a score of 6
This 6 is actually split up into 3 parts
So, we have 1, 2, 3 here
So, with this one, for a score of 2 is your tower and speed
Your rhythm is also a score of 2
And your expression of 2
Your energy is also a score of 2 as well
So, we'll start off with the power and speed
So, with this one, whether it's your blocks, your kicks, your strikes, your punches
Anything that you do, it needs to be nice and strong
And it has to be fast as well
So, it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch
But it has to be both strong and fast to get high in that category
So, the next part is your rhythm
So, the rhythm
When you do start your pattern, there is a rhythm to the pattern
It's not just really fast all the way through
It's not slow all the way through
There's a slow, fast, slow, fast kind of aspect to it as well
So, you do need to kind of work on your rhythm
And that's also a score out of 2
The last bit is your expression of energy
So, what is expression of energy?
So, that's basically how loud you shout
So, how much intensity you have during your pattern as well
So, let's say you're doing your pattern rhythm
Say you're doing your pattern really well
It's really fast and it's strong
Your rhythm is really great
But you're not shouting very loud
Or you can kind of tell
The judges can kind of tell that you're not really confident
You're a little bit nervous
So, that's what we need to kind of improve on as well
So, I'll just come around to this side
So, with this one, for colour belts and black belts
It's actually scored a little bit differently
So, if you're a colour belt, you'll actually
Your average, so where the judges actually mark you from
It's actually from a 1.1
So, this is your average
So, say you did alright
You did average compared to everyone else
Your score for 1, 2 and 3
It'll start from a 1.1
So, if you're less than average in the judges' eyes
You might go down to, say for your power and speed
You might get a 1 or even a 0.9
If you did really great
You might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4
So, each individual category
You need to obviously get as high as you can
If you're a black belt
Generally, depending on the competition
You will be scored from a 1.3
So, 1.3 would be your average
That you start from
So, say your power and speed
Was above average
You might get scored a 1 point, say
Let's say 1.4 for now
Say your rhythm was only about average
It wasn't amazing
It might be just a 1.3
But let's say you didn't shout very loud
So, your expression of energy
You averaged with 1.3
It might drop to, say, a 1.0
So, with this one
We'll comment down to this side
As I was saying, it's a total of 10
So, let's see
For presentation, we had
1.7
1, 2, 3
So, you had a 3.7
And so, you made 15 mistakes
So, with this one obviously
Don't be too discouraged
If you do get pretty high in your mistakes
This is with the judges
We have three judges usually at the panel
And each judge obviously is very subjective
So
From their point of view
You might have made a lot of mistakes
Or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well
So, that's why we have the three judges
And we average it out as well
Okay, so
Say we did our 15 mistakes
Very small mistakes
So, if they're all minus 0.1
It would be 1.5
So, you go 4.0 minus 1.5
Which equals 2.5
So, this would be your accuracy score
So, with our presentation like before
We're saying we got a 3.7 here
So, we add these numbers at the
After the judges are finished scoring
So, you would get for this pattern
A 6.2
Which is actually very good
So, I'll just talk about a little bit more now
About this number here
So, if you're a colour belt
If you're a yellow or above
And you do your patterns
It's not uncommon
Generally for a colour belt
The average is about a 4.5
So, if you get a number between
4 and 5 out of 10
For your pattern
That's actually generally considered pretty good
So, anything above that
You can consider yourself pretty good
If you're a black belt
The average would say
Because we're talking here about
The higher presentation of the average
Anything from 5 to 6
Is actually considered pretty good
And anything over a 7
Is actually considered almost world class
So, if you get a 7
For any of your patterns
You generally need to pat yourself on the back
You did an amazing job
So, we just went through our 4.0 scoring
So, just remember
Accuracy is a 4.0
Presentation is a 6.0
Accuracy is judge during your pattern
Presentation is after
And then we get 2 scores that we add up
And we get that number
So, with this one obviously
Say I was judge number 1
I would give you a 6.2
There was another judge on the other side
Maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did
And maybe this one would be a little bit lower
It might be a 5.something
Another judge on the other side
They scored a little bit higher
So, we get 3 numbers
And then we average that as well
So, I hope this helped you guys
So, make sure you enjoy your 4.0 competitions
And any time
Make sure obviously
You record down your numbers as well
Okay, that makes sense
Okay, we're going to practice reading
Okay, you can practice before you begin to read
Your actual performance or scoring
Use plus and minus to count errors
Click on a choice to rate the presentation
Okay, sure, so
Okay, so this is minor errors
Okay, got it
You cannot pause the video anymore
You're like, you're looking
Oh, you can't pause
Oh, okay, okay, got it
So, it's like you're being a judge for your
Mm-hmm, like I have to do it live
Yeah
Okay, that makes sense
So, major errors
Minor errors
And then right after the performance
You just rate your power and speed
Coordination
And rhythm
And then the expression of energy
From
Okay, okay
Yeah
Okay, that makes sense
So, minor errors, major errors
Okay
Okay, perfect, perfect
Are you ready?
Okay
Let's do the best I can here
Okay, perfect, perfect
Okay
Do a little NCAA